hey what's going on as bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
from Monday July 15th 2019 oh my god the
summer's have over it really isn't half
over but everybody considers that the
summer is over
in at the end of August like that's the
end of it like you're still in school
you know like you can't put the boat in
the water
in September are you talking about this
is the Golden Age of global warming
you can [ __ ] water-ski to like
October 1st yeah enjoy it enjoy the warm
water before it evaporates everybody
that's what I say
get out there put some gas in your boat
let that oil trickle out in the water
let them fish know that you were there
you know I couldn't just do it like the
Native Americans could just make a nice
[ __ ] little boat just paddle along
nice and quiet sneak up on a [ __ ]
badger or a [ __ ] what's in the water
a badger what are those things they look
like badges but they got flat tails
beaver beaver can't [ __ ] do that no
no I got me got me a bar too big Chevy
big-block outboard motors get me up
about 85 mile an hour tell you what
people get the [ __ ] out my way when I
come in I come in doing like 30 miles an
hour bump your [ __ ] all up against the
dock I don't what [ __ ] what
anyways this summer is like half it's
not half where you open yeah you know so
I'm sitting here and I'm I'm talking
right as I do and I don't even know what
the [ __ ] I'm talking about
when is the summer dumbest question
Friday June 21st until September 23rd
we're not how many wait how many want
even [ __ ] that close yet Here I am
blowing the whistle here getting it
buddy panicked like the cop and jaws get
out of the water get out of the water
how many days in summer the length of
Istanbul seen vary between 89 and 93
days not jesus [ __ ] christ so now
what I do I got to go back and I got to
look up June 21st June 21st to September
23rd how many days is that well I can do
that my head that's 40 days the end of
July then there's another 30 that's 71
days plus 20 371 and 23 is [ __ ] 95
[ __ ] dad put your feet up I have a good
time get yourself one of those [ __ ]
awful American beers that they squeeze
lime into for you get yourself a bud
lime well there's one other person will
never be advertising here on the podcast
Budweiser lime I like the not like the
original Budweiser best you know no
offense to Latino community out there
I'm not into the Bud Light
all right plowing ahead here I had a
great week you know another week of the
bull the week seven begins today Oh
Billy [ __ ] uh thespian here Oh Billy
Shakespeare here I got today off I ain't
doing [ __ ]
and actually this Thursday I also have
off on the movie and I'm going into a
edit room and I'm looking at my special
to see if it's gonna have the right look
and the right sound other than that all
the cuts have been made everything's
ready to go and I'm hoping I'm hoping
that that thing will come out sometime
you know before the end of the Saba
right then I've been having such a great
time working out this new hour you know
with some hiccups here and there
you know I was through I did some
stand-up at this club last week and I
was too telling this story where this
lesbian just like went out of her way to
[ __ ] bump into me and you know there
was some I guess gay women in the crowd
or allies I don't know what they were
but God forbid I tell that [ __ ] story
right and they got all [ __ ] pissed
off you know and you know I guess they
talk to each other because they both
immediately I started yelling at the
same time so you know me you know me
when there's a situation like that I do
everything I can to defuse it because
I'm an adult and they start yelling I'm
a fan I shouldn't I just say shut the
[ __ ] up that's what I begin with I
forget what I say to set in the middle
but then they were leaving I was like oh
oh white women are leaving everybody
care oh my god they're packing up when
they're leaving right so they [ __ ]
leave and they go downstairs and I get
offstage and I rumor has it they're at
the bar and it was raining out that
night night war raincoat all right I'm
not in dumb briella umbrellas the only
the way umbrella works is if it's a
light rain falling straight down other
than that the only thing an umbrella
does is it keeps from the bridge of your
nose up dry the rest of you is different
degrees of wet if you're me knees down
is soaked right from your knees to about
your waist is medium and then you know
your shirt you're just chilly I get a
raincoat [ __ ] Hank's down to the
knees calves and you know from Cavs down
still gets soaked okay and I put the
[ __ ] hood up
so anyways I'm walking out and I know
those does you know he's [ __ ] women
are there you know in defense of them it
was a woman show I think slash gay show
I wasn't really sure it was on stage and
there was like paper cutouts of dicks
penises whatever you call so at that
point it's like okay it's gonna get a
little hamburger hairy here okay I get
it but I'm still just gonna do my [ __ ]
you know they considering these are two
groups of people the vibe here that have
been oppressed you know for expressing
themselves clearly they'll be
open-minded to me doing the same right
not what that was not the case you know
it's funny when they left the whole
crowd was Jung like because they're like
you're not funny I'm like where you
talking about the old places laughing
and everybody laughs so then they get up
and [ __ ] leave make a big [ __ ]
scene so then I say but you guys all
havin a good time yeah y'all think you
guys think this is funny right and
they're like yeah so I go alright well
then make sure on Monday make sure on
Monday
you know when they hashtag me and try
and get me in trouble and you guys all
keep your mouth shut that you feel a
certain level of shame about it then I
started imitating them you know peeking
over the walls of their cubicles being
like is it over yet is it over so I'm
having a great time so I get off stage
and all these years of being a comedian
I know good and goddamn well that
whenever somebody gets kicked out of a
comedy club that just means they're just
on the other side of the door and
there's a good chance that they've
actually walked back in because that's
the level of security at a comedy club
they kick them out right to the other
side of the door and then the bouncer
just turns his back and goes well that's
all settled and then the person just
walks back in the amount of [ __ ]
times that I happened to be back in the
day when I was selling a CD Compact Disc
tell you youngsters out there after my
show and some people I would get into it
and it would escalate to the point of
almost a fight and the don't worry we
kicked the guy out and then I'd be
[ __ ] selling CDs and who the [ __ ] is
standing in the line funny [ __ ] ever
right dumb drunk you know sees a line in
front of the guy who wants to punch in
the face so he stands in line to punch
me in the face right you know it's
already you're gonna commit battery not
a self my assault is threatening it's
the threat that the punch is gonna be
thrown battery is the actual hit as far
as I know a lot of people think assault
is hitting somebody let's look that one
up huh
it might differ from state to state and
I know there's a lot of ins and outs and
there's probably a lot of [ __ ] little
lawyers out there gonna try to
difference between assault and battery
the main difference between battery a
battery charge an assault charge is the
actual presence of harm and the threat
of harm
yeah battery is the presence of harm you
punch something in the face and there's
a little bruise there and there's a
little cheekbone the threat of harm is
I'm gonna [ __ ] kill you or you I
don't know if waving a gun around I
don't know what it is
someone can only be charged with battery
if they have caused real physical harm
to someone well a person can be charged
with assault if the mere threat of harm
is present there must be you slip the
punch so anyways I put on my raincoat
izip it up I button it on top of that
right no rain getting in on my [ __ ]
torso so I put the hoodie up and I walk
upstairs and I I mean downstairs and I
am a for informed that the [ __ ] loud
who was at the bar so I just keep my
head down and I [ __ ] walk right by
the bar and I think I'm in the clear I
go to get outside it's [ __ ] humid is
[ __ ] I take the hood off at all of a
sudden I had the same two [ __ ] voices
screaming and yelling I just told them
to go [ __ ] themselves
I really did I did I mean I'll have a
conversation if you want to but if
that's the way you gotta come at me
you're gonna get the same lowest level
of respect that you showin me which is
absolutely nothing and here's the thing
I'm just working the story out there's
gonna be some [ __ ] potholes right let
me tell you something else about those
two [ __ ] allies or lesbians whatever
if I went up there and just started
saying that Trump has sex with his own
son or something crazy about people on
the right they would have been giving me
a standing ovation so there really isn't
anything about stereotypes or anything
like that what it really is about is
about them and their [ __ ] little
kitchen of [ __ ] that they feel is is
beyond reproach so [ __ ] them alright as
I've maintained
if you want to control what a comedian
says do not go to a comedy club
alright hire have a private party hire a
comic with the list of topics that are
off-limits and the rest of the [ __ ] that
you can talk about then you can complain
other than that shut the [ __ ] up that's
how I look at you know not saying you
can't heckle alright not saying you
can't help oh but when you're saying you
know you're not even funny while I'm in
the middle of killing you what you
should say we don't find you funny
whatever I don't give a [ __ ] now I'm
telling you what to say say whatever the
[ __ ] you want to say so the very next
night I go out I do the same bit I had
two little adjustments to it it all goes
[ __ ] smoothly and this time I'm down
in the village you know right near NYU
it's like beyond liberal and the whole
[ __ ] thing kills so I'm feeling great
about that then I'm on stage and I I was
doing the abortion bit and at one point
I look over and I see this guy who's
laughing so hard he literally has like
his head in his hands and he's shaking
his head and it's literally every reason
why you become a comedian it's for that
[ __ ] laugh and I couldn't tell if he
was laughing like finally somebody's
saying when I think on this subject or I
can't believe he just said that I don't
know what it is but this guy was
laughing so hard and was having such a
good time he actually made me laugh it
was like perfect which then made me go
even farther and I rift this other line
and then I heard this comedian Greer
Barnes who's one of my favorite comics
of all time and also one of the most
difficult comics I've ever tried to
follow I made him laugh with that line
and that was it there was literally the
the the entire [ __ ] reason I ever got
up to do static make people die laughing
in the crowd and then have comics that I
love and respect laugh at my jokes and
think that I'm funny that was it that
was that's why I did it not to get in
arguments with [ __ ] [ __ ] in the
crowd that's not why I did it
did it do it
so had the perfect night and I was doing
a bunch of sets because I had to get
ready cuz uh Dave Chappelle is in town
doing a two-week run at a Broadway
theater sold out wire-to-wire and I was
gonna get to do stand-up on Broadway so
you know I'm walking over there with my
lovely wife and a buddy of mine and we
[ __ ] get over to the theater there's
all these people in the streets too much
it's like jeez what the [ __ ] are all
these people doing in the street this is
so crowded now and I made a comment
about how crowded Times Square is
compared to ten years ago and my buddy's
like I don't know you look back those
old-time pictures there's a bunch of
people in the streets and it's just like
yeah but there weren't this many you
know and also ten years ago there
weren't that many he goes now there were
it's like nah well I don't know 20 years
ago there wasn't and he argues with me
that there were and I was like dude 20
years ago when I first came at 25 years
ago it was still sort of taxi driver you
know jerk-off shops down there in Times
Square that wasn't like the [ __ ] M&M
store with the peeps show in the lobby
you know that she had to walk by and
people [ __ ] jerking off and that guy
with the [ __ ] the guy on cleanup duty
and all that [ __ ] it wasn't like that
and it's just there was all of these
[ __ ] people and I have heard that the
population has gone up by like a million
people in the last 25 years over here
but anyway that we got our answer when
we got to the theater and they opened
the door and it was like pitch black in
there and they said there's a power
outage on this side of Broadway it was
so crazy
the West the East Side aha of Broadway
was totally lit up everything looked
normal and then the the west side was
totally dark and I got this really cool
picture that I ended up taking put it up
on my Instagram of Times Square where
half of it is lit up like it always is
and the other half it's just blank
screens so we go in there and as all
these comics and [ __ ]
some who gonna be on the show some we
were just hanging out we're all in there
with like our [ __ ] cell phones with
the flashlights and we just I just sort
of walked out on the stage to look at it
they had the emergency lights on which
was really cool I saw this beautiful
theater was 7:30 I was just thinking
like I it's 7:30
you know the show doesn't start till
8:00 they're gonna figure something out
there's too much money to be that's
being lost right now
that there isn't some sort of emergency
generator or some [ __ ] that's gonna
happen and then it was 7:45 and then it
was 5 of 8 and then at 8 o'clock
somebody just said all right in 8:15 if
these aren't on officially we have to
call it and I just started getting this
sinking feeling that I was not going to
be able to do a set and then get to
watch the master himself Dave Chappelle
do 90 minutes two hours whatever he was
going to do and lo and behold 8:15 came
around the lights didn't come on so I
did not get to open for Dave did not get
to tell my dick and [ __ ] jokes on
Broadway and yeah and I didn't get to
watch Dave most importantly because
they've lived like at this point
literally like transcends standup it's
like it's its own deal you know so now
we're like f [ __ ] and then we all go
outside and there's just a group of us
comics and [ __ ] and now there's just
people walking in the streets
it's like bedlam on the west side right
so my buddy goes let's walk this way
he's pointing West further into the
blackout to try and get a cab and it's
like no dude let's go to East where
there's still civilization lights are on
and because the lights are on people are
not walking in the streets and they're
abiding by the laws so we got over there
and we walked over to about 6th Avenue
and we get over to 6th Avenue and my
buddy goes let's keep going and go to
Fifth Avenue and try and get a cab I'm
like don't you think everybody's doing
that right now none of these cars are
moving so we [ __ ] make a quick plan
let's just go down to the cellar so we
all walked like 50 blocks
down to the Comedy Cellar just laughing
and telling stories and just had like
ended up having like the best time
walking all the way down there
fortunately my wife had Ward's some
comfortable shoes even though she still
looked like a knockout she had the comfy
shoes on and because ladies you know you
have to have a little bit of pain to
look good
sorry so we all just walked down was it
six to Avenue did we go down bra no we
end up going down Broadway at Macy's we
switched to Broadway and then we just
went all the way down switch to Fifth
Avenue 23rd Street went right down to
[ __ ] Washington Square Park walked
around the block and we got down there
and Chapelle was on stage he ended up
bringing me up
I had another great time wasn't Broadway
but it was still fun and we just hung
out and end up being a great thing
anyways because my lovely wife used to
work on tough crowd so she knows all
those guys and they all hadn't seen her
in a minute so she enough having a good
time and end up being great and then
Bobby Kelly greatest guy you ever ended
up giving us a ride back uptown and it
was was one of those New York nights so
anyway what do we got here how much time
was the time for the [ __ ] advertising
here look at that 19 [ __ ] minutes just
babbling on and babbling on you don't
haven't been talked bit totally getting
into was reading this Ken Stabler book
because it's getting me totally back
into like the 70s NFL that it was my
favorite time ever and there was all
these great defense nicknames back then
and I never knew that the Raiders their
secondary was called the soul Patrol I
had never heard that that's was the I
guess because it was all black secondary
which was that like a big deal back then
I don't know I don't know Jack Tatum
Willie Brown skip Thomas aka dr. death
Jack Tatum the assassin old man Willie
Brown and George Atkinson and so I
actually looked up to see if they made a
t-shirt that had soul patrol on I mean I
would be [ __ ] great but
the only thing you have is there's
really weird radar Jersey then it just
says soul Patrol and then has all their
numbers it just doesn't look good looks
like an old person's phone with the
numbers of gigantic you know when they
would push the buttons back in the day
so I came across this website and they
were talking about all the great
nicknames course doomsday and Steel
Curtain of the two greatest than purple
PPR as I'm concerned then the purple
people eaters doomsday defense was the
Dallas Cowboys the Steel Curtain was the
super Steelers that won four Super Bowls
unheard of doubled the Green Bay Packers
at that point the Dolphins and anybody
else would want to at that point and
what else did they have that it just
kind of drops off the killer bees which
was there was the Dolphins defense that
had all those guys with the same last
name began with the B monsters of the
Midway is a great one for the Chicago
Bears but I heard they actually took
they appropriated that name from a
college team out there in Illinois I
can't remember the other ones but the
one that I came across they had in the
1977 Atlanta Falcons that called the
grits blitz and then I saw these
articles that were saying that the 1977
Atlanta Falcons was actually the
greatest defense ever and statistically
the way they were presenting the numbers
it held up over the 85 Bears who say the
2000 Ravens with us the comparisons but
what they didn't take into consideration
was it was a 14-game see they only went
seven and seven I guess their offense
was completely anemic I'm not saying
they weren't great but to say that the
greatest of all time you look at their
schedule they played in the NFC West
they played the 49ers in the Saints four
times and both those teams were [ __ ]
horrific and and then on top of that
eight out of the their 14 games were
against teams with losing records so and
then you also combined
fact with like I don't know it just all
all the rule changes for offense and all
of that crap the 85 Bears I guess to
make it fair the 85 Bears in the 2000
Ravens would not put up the same numbers
but I don't it's always how but it's a
great argument that they're making and
it also shines light on a forgotten
incredible defense they put up
statistically the best numbers of all
time in a 14 game season I think that's
a big thing when you don't when you go
to 16 games that should be you know the
same way the NFL doesn't count NFL
championships for some reason versus
Super Bowls I think that they there
should be a different time for like 14
game season versus a 16-game season and
then also how much the game has changed
and it's just all about offense how much
they throw the ball I was actually
reading in that Ken Stabler book he was
talking about it he had a game where he
threw 47 times and he goes and you know
any time you have to throw the ball that
many times you're not gonna win which is
hilarious because that's exactly how the
game is played now and if you go to the
NFL encyclopedia whatever the NFL
reference whatever the [ __ ] it is to
show you how much the game has changed
if you look up the top like 50 running
backs of all time there's only like four
or five active guys and if you look up
the top like 50 passers of all time five
of the top eight all-time are still
active number one is still playing and
like and then two of the other guys in
the top eight are Peyton Manning who
retired in 2015 and Brett Favre who
retired in 2010 so you're talking about
like basically six of the top eight five
of the top eight are still playing and
six of the top eight we're still playing
as of 2010 it just goes to show how much
that how much the the game has changed
but it's actually a really interesting
thing to to look up that that 1977
Atlanta Falcons defense because I that
somehow escaped me there was no ESPN
back then also
I started watching football in 77 I was
in third grade
and I think I started watching and like
the playoffs
I remember the playoff set you remember
Tampa I want to say made the playoffs
one of those years and they beat like
the Rams nine to nothing or lost to the
Rams nine to nothing maybe that was
seven to 79 it's [ __ ] how I could
remember that but can't remember a movie
I literally just saw like how it ends
over though the name is somebody who's
in it all right let's do a little bit of
advertising here shall we oh no what is
this what is this this is not the right
stuff I got the wrong advertising yet
hang on a second goddamn it bill what is
wrong with you
are you kidding me
are you [ __ ] kidding me is this
thorne oh here it is here it is okay
okay okay all right
simply safe did you know most breakups
happen in between six break-ins not
breakups break-ins happen between 6:00
a.m. and 6:00 p.m. I did not know that
most breakups happen between 6:00 p.m.
and 6:00 a.m. unless you go with the
[ __ ] email breakup huh you guys into
that is that are you Millennials to it
wait 6:00 a.m. to 6:00 p.m. in the
middle of the day they say oh these
[ __ ] arrogant bastards you know why
that is is because everything's dressed
down now they used to have just dressed
down Fridays and the rest of the week
you go you always had to dress up you
know now you can just wear whatever you
want when you go to work it's the same
thing with people that break into your
house like back in the day like someone
broke in your house they dressed like a
cat burglar they have the little [ __ ]
Zorro mask on they don't do it anymore
they just dressed in all casuals so you
think it's a [ __ ] landscaper
the next thing you know somebody stole
you find Shina
simply say protects your whole home
every window room indoor with 24/7
monitoring for just a fraction of the
cost their police dispatch is up to 3.5
times faster because
use video verification there's no
contract hidden fees or fine print it's
designed to blend right into your home
no wires no drilling it's easy to order
and easy to set up usually in under an
hour our simply safe has won a ton of
awards from CNET to the New York Times
wire cutter prices are always fair and
honest around-the-clock monitoring is
just $15 a month visit simply safe bird
comm and you'll get free shipping and a
60-day risk trial a 60 day risk-free
trial good Lord Bell you got nothing to
lose go now and be sure you go go now
and be sure you go to simply safe bird
calm Jesus so they know our show sent
you that simply safe bird calm sorry uh
don't worry there's only one more read
left okay here we go dance jhatka amma
no one really has time to go to the post
office you're busy who's got the time
for all that traffic parking lugging all
your mail and packages it's a real
hassle man well we should have more time
with all the technology that was the
pipe dream we all chased right in the
future with all this technology we were
supposed to be working less somehow
we're all working more number one used
to watch the Jetson and Jetson and
George would get to work his little
flying car would you turning turn into a
briefcase and he would just somehow be
able to carry that thing in and he would
sit down at his desk and be like all
these three day work weeks are murder
he worked Monday Tuesday Wednesday and
he had Thursday Friday Saturday Sunday
off how [ __ ] great would that be
I actually think would be great for the
population problem because people would
get so drunk and so fat that they'd
probably shave 15 years off their life
anyways that's why you need stamps calm
one of the most popular time-saving
tools for small businesses whether
you're in a small office sending
invoices and online sellers shipping out
products or even a warehouse sending
thousands of packages a day stamps.com
can handle it all with ease simply use
your computer to print US postage 24/7
for any letter any package any class of
mail anywhere
want to send once your mail is ready
just hand it to your mail carrier or
drop it in the mailbox it's that simple
stamps.com is a no-brainer saving you
time and money
it's no wonder over 700 thousand small
businesses already use stamps calm right
now my listeners can get a special offer
that includes a four week trial plus
free postage and a digital scale without
any long-term commitment just go to
stamps com click on the microphone at
the top of the homepage and type in
burpee you are our that stamps comm
enter ber all right and with that with
that is it time for the questions the
questions the questions I believe it is
all right tinfoil hat podcast dear Billy
right on read love it a year or so ago I
started listening to Sam Tripoli's tin
foil podcast while looking for more
podcasts on your network the all things
comedy network and by the way thank you
to everybody that watched Ian Edwards
stand-up special on Comedy Central was a
big hit the ratings were awesome please
look for it online at comedy central.com
okay one of the finest things I remember
him talking about being San Tripoli
about was the Epstein pedophile guy and
how it was [ __ ] up that he never went
to jail for a bunch of stuff he got
caught for I was listening at work so I
had plenty of time to Google and confirm
that even a year ago there was enough
evidence to fry this guy in the chair
yeah rich people who have their own
islands they don't go to jail one day I
brought it up to some co-workers during
a conversation about how rich people
don't go to jail unless other rich
people want them to that isn't that the
truth and they laughed this off like it
couldn't be true because the official
story is always the story according to
these guys meaning the guys protecting
the person cut to last Friday I reminded
them that they said there's no way a
well-known billionaire could ever evade
heinous crimes like that one of the
reasons was quote why wouldn't any new
Shanker want to be the one to break that
news and get all the attention maybe
because they don't actually decide what
they report anyway go [ __ ] yourself and
do the chip chip person podcasts while
you're in New York please
I would love to do that hey I was hoping
you were gonna say what your friend said
when you said that you were right yeah
absolutely they don't go to [ __ ] jail
I don't understand people that just sort
of believe in the whole like they
believe that this system is not that
certain people don't have advantages I
don't understand that on any level any
level whatsoever there's always you know
and the kind of thing about it is is
regular people walking around like if
there's a long line outside the club
okay but you know the bouncer oh you
know somebody who works there oh your
friend knows somebody you're gonna get
in you're not gonna have to wait in the
line like everybody else you know how
that works that little that simple
example goes all the way up to
ridiculous levels of power they know
somebody inside and then they're not
gonna get [ __ ] punished you know if
you're a billionaire and you have your
own Island and you're a [ __ ]
pedophile how you stay out of jail is
you just donate to [ __ ] politicians
campaigns give money to the cops you
just do [ __ ] like that
and then they don't want to bite the
hand that feeds and then they [ __ ]
look the other way that's that's that's
how it works I know I'm overly
simplifying it but yeah I mean that guy
I don't know I mean I actually think
putting into death would be too [ __ ]
good for him those people should just be
shot in a street like [ __ ] dog well
you don't other people to see him be
traumatized by seeing someone get their
brains blown out but no that guy should
have to beg for mercy the way his
victims did and then he should be shown
the same mercy that he showed those kids
like those people who do that that I
don't you don't light him on fire
I am okay with that
all right I'm sorry how do you get back
to the comedy there I've been addicted
to what I got back into watch an
American greed when I returned an
America greed they always have to do
like the opposite he was setting sail to
have a vacation in the only continent he
had never been to Antarctica but things
were about to heat up it's always that
as he rode the elevator up to the
penthouse his personal life was about to
come crashing down American greed you
know when you watch American greed you
really get annoyed by the Americans who
are greedy but after a while you watch
that show long enough you're like wow
there are a lot of [ __ ] stupid people
out there I met him and he seemed real
nice and then you know he paid for my
Wild Wings and then asked me if I could
give him $10,000 and he seemed so nice
he was calling me miss and ma'am then he
paid from a buffalo wings so I gave him
$10,000 came back a week later wanted
another 10 when I said no he just
started yelling at me tearing up my
[ __ ] house
we retired all right [ __ ] motorcycles
all right this sounds like is gonna be
about as open-minded as my opinion hey
ready mercury one of my friends actually
said ready Burke mercury took it to
another level longtime fan blah blah
Bill I loved your topic on motorcycles
and I by the way mo I love [ __ ]
motorcycles alright I watched another
one of those MotoGP I finally watched
that whole race where Jorge Lorenzo took
out Dodie take out he took out Valentino
Rossi Davitt CEO so and maverick
what's-his-face there the guy who's been
t-boned like [ __ ] four races this
year was it maverick
venez I don't know if I can say it I
don't know what why do I try viñales
right vignette I don't know I'm too
white to say pronounce his name right
yet I'll get it I'll get it
I watched that race and still it was
exciting even though you know Marc
Marquez was out in front in a Formula
one kind of way where the race was
[ __ ] over unless he just wiped out
like he did in Austin Texas it was still
exciting watching people fighting for
the second third and fourth positions
all sort of passed and going on it was
photos I was still a great race I felt
bad for the people that were there
because I imagined most of them were
fans of those four [ __ ] people that
were now out of the race immediately
means within like the first ten laps
that had happened oh by the way
congratulations to Lewis Hamilton being
the first Formula One driver ever to win
the British Grand Prix six times and of
course he gets like the lower level of
[ __ ] like racism is back the way
cocaine is racism like cocaine is back
like like really overt like people in
the press just asking like all kinds of
just [ __ ] racist they were questioning
his level of Britishness
it's like where was he born
well there you go where did he grow up
break break
there you go what is the question oh
he's got too much of a tan for you
because he lives in Monaco or some [ __ ]
like most of the race car drivers and
there's all kinds of British people that
live in [ __ ] Spain and France and all
of that [ __ ] it's just so [ __ ] ugly
they just can't handle the fact that
somebody who isn't white broke a [ __ ]
record to this [ __ ] day it's like
Wilt Chamberlain still playing I don't
know
disappointing I did like what's-his-face
teammate there said he's like dude we
all [ __ ] live in Monaco Valtteri
Bottas avid is team mates back that's a
good thing anyway where was I we talk in
motor so but I do love motorcycles and
but you know when people on motorcycle a
hundred percent of the time are blaming
the way people drive and then they don't
look at a lot of their peers the way
they ride on motorcycles and you know
the amount of [ __ ] laws they break
every quarter mile it's a little
ridiculous all right so hey ready
mercury longtime fan blah blah blah bill
I loved your topic on motorcycles I've
ranted and raved about those stupid
[ __ ] driving 120 miles stupid [ __ ]
driving 120 miles per hour weaving in
and out of traffic then having the balls
to [ __ ] and make watch out for
motorcycle t-shirts stickers and you
name it how about you guys drive like
responsible drivers and maybe you
wouldn't die all right now yeah there's
a point to be made with what you're
saying there there is a lot like they
act like motorcyclists when they bring
up that you know telling you to look out
for riders which you should certainly do
they act like you know 99% of the time
it's it's the guy in the cars fault what
you have to understand if you're riding
a motorcycle is that people just can't
[ __ ] see you you know nobody's trying
to [ __ ] up their own car so when
somebody pulls out in front of somebody
that's on a motorcycle it's because they
can't [ __ ] see it's inherently
[ __ ] dangerous which by the way for
all
non motorcycle riders that's why
motorcycles are so loud
for all you [ __ ] hipster nerd douches
out there who like I think it's you know
it's because of some underlying
insecurity that they have to be so
[ __ ] loud that's because you can't
see him and they don't want to die
alright not saying that there's not
insecure people on motorcycles sometimes
but there's also plenty of insecure
people driving cars who don't have the
balls to ride a motorcycle
alright so anyway so how about you guys
drive like responsible drivers and maybe
you wouldn't die well that's not on a
percent truth they would still die
because people don't drive if they
should be responsible driving on both
sides anyways he goes I'm not talking
about the Harley riders it's those
douche bags on the [ __ ] bikes that go
way too fast
yeah ok I agree with this who drive like
an arrogant prick weaving through all of
us trying to drive home from work it's
scary to see them zipping past you
because one mistake by you and they're
dead and you have to face the concept
consequences of their reckless actions
yeah like if somebody they come flying
by and then they run into you I would
not want to have one of those guys in
one of those [ __ ] Japanese super
bikes t-boned me on my driver's side
door I just don't think my crumple zones
are gonna save me from significant if
not fatal injury because at the end of
the day those bikes wait I don't how
much they wait for 500 pounds coming at
ya a hundred miles an hour I don't think
my doors gonna be able to handle that
anyways he says that's my piece thanks
for listening and go [ __ ] yourself PS
can you tell us the name of the movie
you're doing yet would love to check it
out well it's not out yet and it's it
just has a working title you know in a
perfect world like they'd have like I
would say car and truck roads and then
motorcycle roads and then a bike lane we
could all stay away from each other but
I would be just as afraid to ride in an
all motorcycle lane because then I think
that those people who ride like lunatics
amongst cars would be even more [ __ ]
out
I don't know it's not even arrogant what
it is is it's just it's a young person
brain where you just feel like it's not
gonna be you I'm not gonna be the one
that dies or gets [ __ ] up or loses a
leg or something like that and yeah I
don't know but having said that I
absolutely absolutely [ __ ] love
motorcycles and I wish that they were
safer if they were I would ride one or I
wish I lived in an 800 place in the
middle of nowhere where I could actually
ride and not feel like you know I don't
just even just riding one in general
it's just even on a straightaway this
the speed limit is so [ __ ] dangerous
like you ever just think about how how
[ __ ] up it is that you when you're
driving down the street because the
rules of the road and that that yellow
line painted in the middle that like
you're driving like whatever 50 miles an
hour the other person is driving 45 50
and you guys pass each other head-on
going the exact opposite direction that
close going around turns and all of that
and it all works because you maintain
the rules of the road but if you were on
an unmarked like just parking lot and
you both drive like that you'd both slow
down like whoa whoa what is this guy
doing what is this guy doing but you
kind of take that for granted and you
get the fact that people text now this
is why I got rid of the motorcycle I had
for probably about six weeks maybe two
months is I was riding down Santa Monica
Boulevard scared to death by the way and
I got out too near where the Playboy
Mansion used to be and I was going
around a turn and this guy was coming
around the turn too fast and he was like
on the double line and I was towards the
double line because you kind of have to
pick a side because in the middle of the
road is where all the [ __ ]
transmission fluid oil and [ __ ] from
cars leaks and you could wipe out in a
turn so I was leaning into the turn and
he came over so it just felt like his
car was gonna hit my head so I had to
stand the bike up for like a split
second but it felt like
[ __ ] 20 seconds in a turn and then I
had to lean again and I was thinking I
was getting into that oil am I gonna go
sliding into these [ __ ] trees
I went from am I gonna [ __ ] lose my
head too am I gonna have my leg ripped
off and then slam into these trees and
get paralyzed in like about them second
and a half and I didn't happen
fortunately and then I rode the bike all
the way to the beach we stopped to get
some food or something I got off the
bike and I was shaking just
ever-so-slight just a little bit and I
was thinking like alright is that from
the vibration of the bike what the
[ __ ] going on here I was like oh no
that's cuz I'm scared shitless so we
finished eating I got back on the bike
and I said a prayer which I never do
it's just like God if you [ __ ] get
this me and this bike back in one piece
I promise you I will never ride this
thing again and I didn't I got it into
the garage and I just said [ __ ] it like
this isn't for me I am NOT a there's a
certain type of personality I just I I
don't know I like playing drums I need
my legs okay I got to chase my kid
around I can't do this I'm a stand-up
comedian okay I can't come Hopalong on
[ __ ] stage and I just like I can't
[ __ ] do this but I would be lying to
you if I told you that I didn't miss it
every time I saw one like I actually
remember Chappelle telling me when he
found out that I was started was
starting to ride he was very excited and
he asked me have you ridden a Ducati yet
and I said no he said dude I'm telling
you you ride one of those things you'll
never write another bike and it's to
this day it bugs me I never ridden a
Ducati and I will someday but I will
ride one at a track where there's no
other cars I mean maybe that's the way
to do it but I think you would just get
sick of it after a while like if you
just put it on a trailer or the back of
your truck and just brought it to a
track you rode around but then you have
to deal with everybody had to track
riding like [ __ ] lunatics where I
just want to sort of cruise around we
were going into a turd I don't know I'll
figure it it some day I'll figure it out
all right us out of cash a billy
bankrupt good news and bad news good
news you were right bad news well the US
Treasury announced this week that we
could run out of cash by September I
also read that the u.s. budget deficit
is at minus 23 percent so we can't
afford what it'll cost to run the
country when they balance the books at
the end of the day can't wait to get my
hands on those freshly printed three
dollar bills they'll print to take our
attention away from it yeah this happens
every single year it is the [ __ ]
Ponzi scheme and we're all tied into it
like I don't know what's going to happen
but you know what should happen is it
should go bankrupt all the people that
got us to this point should go to jail
and we should start over again and we
should have a system set up where this
can't happen again and you know from
what I used to read on it once you had
the Federal Reserve and that our money
was being printed by a private
corporation it was an inevitable that
some day this day was gonna [ __ ]
happen the only thing that I can say the
only positive thing that I can say is
that I don't think that you know the
Federal Reserve wants to destroy this
country unless you believe in the New
World Order which is a [ __ ] pipe
dream but I wouldn't underestimate them
trying to go after that there's no way
you're gonna get everybody in the world
on the same [ __ ] page okay you can't
even get the Middle East on the same
[ __ ] page was what the [ __ ] we've
been trying to do the same page being
our page which yeah why wouldn't they go
for that hey you should live the way we
say you should live and then we should
control your natural resources
all right girlfriend's pet no boy what
does she have what does she have she got
one of those little dogs does it [ __ ]
yipping at you all right girlfriends pet
hey Bill loved the podcasts always good
for a laugh I'm a twenty year old man
and I got this girlfriend I got this
girlfriend you already sound like you're
out
the door you don't I don't have a
girlfriend I got this girlfriend like I
got this problem I love her very much
okay well okay I guess I was wrong her
pet bird not so much you see this bird
bird is small only a parakeet but it it
sure is aggressive towards me and anyone
but her and her mother so aggressive
that even being in the same room makes
it dive-bomb me almost every time I'm
there it bites her even sometimes and
draws blood well put the thing in a
[ __ ] cage anyways now I kind of like
this bird even though it [ __ ] hates
me we lay in bed and watch TV together
what the girl the bird and me you know
Jesus not just the bird and I okay cool
now I don't want to be a [ __ ] and tell
her that she needs to put the bird away
while we were hanging out but it starts
to get out of hand so far so that she
starts to cry whenever I suggest some
alone time with just us she cries over
that what that's [ __ ] weird ooh I
would slowly back out of the room be
like hey I'm gonna go get some birdseed
I'll see you later that's it yeah dude
that's [ __ ] that that is that is
bizarre now this girl whom I love is
very sensitive and emotional and I'm an
angry ass oh boy
so your advice about screaming in the
car as I go home usually works but this
is where I draw the line she has told me
multiple times that if she has to pick
between me or the bird it's the bird
every day of the week well there you go
there's your answer you can't get mad at
honesty sir you just have to act
accordingly this pisses me off
how can she choose that [ __ ] animal
over me I get it she loves it but I'm
her boyfriend yeah you're also not
trying to hurt the bird the birds trying
to hurt you but I'm her boyfriend in
over a year and I'm honestly insulted so
bill how do I ask her to just put the
bird away for a little while every day
so that we can hang out on
anyways thanks a lot bill and come to
South Dakota sometime this is what I
would do I'd stop going over there and
just say listen I respect the fact that
you love that bird so much okay I
respect your wishes
okay but I also respect my own
well-being and I don't want to you know
if I had an animal that was hurting you
there would be no question it would not
be in the room if you came over okay
I've asked you nicely you don't want to
do it I respect that so if you want to
hang out with me come over my place
leave the bird at home all right if you
ever want me to come over there again
you have to put that [ __ ] bird away
don't say [ __ ] you got to put the
bird away it's not fair to me all right
the [ __ ] thing bites you I think he
even said drew blood one time so yeah
that's the deal I mean the birds not
gonna listen to her day is is it I don't
know I said I would do I don't know
buddy I don't I don't know I don't know
about that draft pick either you know I
guess I could see if she was 13 but
she's 20 years old and she is like that
about a [ __ ] bird I don't know that's
[ __ ] weird like I said I get loving
animals I love animals too but not to
the point where I choose them over
another [ __ ] human being when they're
trying to hurt that human being all
right here we go guys insecure about
their girlfriends hey Billy bro stash I
was going on a run yesterday and we were
and was finishing up as I got back into
my neighborhood what I was going on a
run yesterday and was finishing up as I
got into my neighborhood I live in the
law I live in the Lower East Side of
Manhattan which as you might guess gets
a lot of foot traffic on a Saturday
afternoon anyway one of the people I saw
was this big dude and his girlfriend I
kind of looked at them for two or three
seconds as I was jogging which i think
is totally Noir
thing to do two or three sad I know
three is a little that's a little
forward as I was passing them the guy
leans in and says in a stern voice keep
your eyes up buddy I didn't understand
what he said at first I kept jogging but
if I did I definitely would have said
some [ __ ] back I guess he thought I was
checking out his girlfriend I really
don't understand people who think like
that in my mind if I know I'm the only
one [ __ ] my girl I could care less if
other people look yeah cuz you looked to
you like goddamn that woman's gorgeous I
want to talk to her then she talked back
and now you're going out yeah if you're
with the beautiful woman you got expect
guys are gonna look this dude looked
like he could have been a football
player so he probably has a big ego hey
easy now now we're making all kinds of
judgment I love this [ __ ] football
players get like they're all [ __ ]
[ __ ] and nerds are all these nice
empathetic people they're not they're
passive-aggressive [ __ ] and they would
be the way football players the
stereotypical ones behave if they were
bigger and knew how to fight anyways I'm
curious how a woman would feel if for a
man look at look at that [ __ ] [ __ ]
on Facebook look how he all of a sudden
that little [ __ ] gets power you can't
even cancel your [ __ ] account enough
with the hackey trashing of football
players [ __ ] the real [ __ ] problem
these [ __ ] nerds these spineless
[ __ ] nerds who are creating all these
spyware and all of this [ __ ] [ __ ]
that goes on out there these [ __ ]
algorithms where they're peeking into
your life they're [ __ ] weirdos
what does the football player do hang
you by your underwear supposed to these
[ __ ] [ __ ] building nationwide
[ __ ] systems to spy on their own
[ __ ] people then one of them finally
grows the spine Snowden and we all turn
our back on them and just leave that guy
twisting in the wind somewhere in
[ __ ] Russia that guy's a [ __ ] hero
anyway anyways this dude like he could
have like you could have been a football
player so he probably has a big ego but
to me it just seems really insecure I'm
curious how a will
would feel if a man did that as well
it's not like I was Oakland the girl I
think some of them like it most of them
don't some of them you know are just the
biggest [ __ ] show if you have a guy like
that they like you know the guy getting
all [ __ ] pissed off and fighting over
him anyways as ice a side note something
similar happened a year ago at the beach
when I was admittedly checking this
older woman out great cans alright dude
now I don't know this is the second time
second instant isn't it her husband saw
me and walked up to me and started
yelling why you check it out my wife
yeah dude all right there there's
something that I'm [ __ ] all this is you
first I said I don't know what you're
talking about but he persisted luckily I
had six inches of height and maybe
thirty pounds on him so I looked at me
and said so what man and he walked away
curious to hear your opinion on guys
like this or if you think I'm an [ __ ]
thanks and go [ __ ] yourself yeah well
you need that you need to get better at
your leering game okay she's got a nice
set of tits you're gonna look you're a
man right same way if you had a bulging
[ __ ] wallet of cash they'd be
checking you out I had to get one in
yeah I would just be a little more
discreet about it you know and I'd be a
little more respectful okay for guys
what the woman and she's hot you want to
look just look when he's not looking
that's it but you're gonna look the same
way that [ __ ] [ __ ] who's getting
upset he looks to everybody looks guys
look women no we look that's why they
walk around half their [ __ ] titties
hanging out because they know then I can
have to buy a drink okay and then they
lying gonna know I thought I looked cute
you can't look cute without a hat with
you without your butt crack peeking out
of the back of your [ __ ] pants would
you come here to fix the sink II came
here to [ __ ] somebody all right that's
the podcast that's the end of the
ignorance for this week you know reading
this Kent's table book I'm coming to the
end here he's been traded to the Houston
Oilers for Dan Pastorini and I realized
Dan passed
Rini also wrote a book and i remember
john madden wrote a book so i was
curious to read the john madden book
because he's going to be talking about
coaching the Raiders for those ten years
and when they got Ken Stabler and his
feelings on him and then I can read Dan
Pastorini because I remember he went to
Oakland and it didn't work out but I
guess afterwards he became like a drag
racer like a successful drag racer and
he used to like to raise hell and go out
like Ken Stabler did so I got to read
that book too and considering the summer
doesn't end at the end of August I have
plenty of time to read these books so
I'm gonna refinish the Ken Stabler book
today and then I'm going to go onto the
Dan Pastorini book you know these are
and then I could say I'm a really
well-read guy all right that's the
podcast go [ __ ] yourselves
and I will check in on you on Thursday